modern shooters love to let you spruce
up your weapons with a whole range of
attachments sights grips suppressors and
everything in between it's a phenomenon
that has spanned the shooter genre for
longer than we think
but due to assumptions and balances to
gameplay many developers don't always
get it right when it comes to the bits
and pieces you can throw on your firearm
i've come here to the royal army's
museum in the uk to talk to jonathan
ferguson about just how accurate games
are in their portrayal of weapon
attachments players are now used to the
ability to change
accessories they're used to that and
they now want to do it to stuff that is
in a strict military setting in the past
when those attachments didn't exist
from scopes and flash suppressors to
four grips and drum magazines
what the heck do all these gadgets
actually do
[Music]
so many shooters today offer an
unprecedented level of customization to
the firearms with which they allow
players to do virtual battle from
battlefield 2042's active attachment
system call of duty's slew of accessory
slots to escape from tarkov's absolutely
daft level of weaponry tailoring the
amount of these accessories can change
up gameplay and the level of detail a
player can go into when it comes to
customizing their rifle is a fairly
recent phenomenon with scenes of the
idea appearing only 20 years ago
one of the earliest examples can be
found in the cyberpunk dystopian world
of 2000's action rpg deus ex this is a
game that is still commended for the
amount of choice and player agency that
can be found through its story in open
world so it makes a lot of sense that
some of the variety would bleed into the
weapons available to the player
the tactical shooter genre also did a
lot for players who wanted to tinker
with their tools games like socom 3 and
the rainbow 6 lockdown and vegas titles
allowed players to feel that tactical
vibe if only through the ability to add
things like scopes suppressors high
capacity mags or red dot sights however
the first time we saw weapon
customization hit the mainstream and see
big commercial success was with 2007's
call of duty 4 modern warfare
weapon progression and customization was
something that infinity ward used to
make their modern shooter feel more
modern
the ability to add accessories to
firearms even in this basic sense with
only a single slot to offer was
something mainstream shooter fans
weren't used to getting their hands on
and it helped call of duty 4 stand out a
little higher among other shooters and
with those attachments being tied to a
progression levelling and challenge
based system it gave players more
objectives and rewards to chase allowing
for the game to feel all the more
rewarding and engaging this for better
or worse is still an upward trend that
follows call of duty today to the point
where the franchise would be
unrecognizable without some degree of
weapon tinkering even if that means we
end up with the cursed creations of
vanguard
and of course a genre that is still
fairly young in the world of games but
say for a few exceptions has relied
heavily on firearms accessories is the
battle royale genre games like
playerunknown's battlegrounds provide
you with a weapon that's bare bones in
comparison to its potential if you could
only find the right bits and pieces to
throw onto it with many of them feeling
like completely different firearms once
all its accessory slots are filled
this is important to the gameplay loop
of pubg as well as many others it drives
you forward ever more searching for loot
not only hungry for new weapons and meds
but for the best attachments to aid you
in your fight in the final circle
for some games it's a way to make a
limited amount of weapons feel like
dozens of diverse firearms by just
swapping other accessories which brings
us to the very upper end of what you can
do with your virtual weapon of choice
escape from tarkov allows for a truly
unprecedented level of customization for
any pmc that's brave enough to loot the
required add-ons and extract them out of
dangerous territory it's an essential
element of tarkov with one of its
pillars of gameplay being the use of the
best gadgets you can get your hands on
and then stripping those very same
accessories off of enemy weapons to take
back to your stash this game is a
personal favorite of mine and one of the
many things that attracted me to it was
the absolutely crazy amount of
accessories and add-ons that you can
throw onto your weapon but tarkov leans
a little more into the realms of realism
as to how the weapon handles and
operates changing quite drastically if
you're throwing all sorts of gadgetry on
it with things like its weight and
ergonomics being affected
the example of taka brings up the
conversation as to just how accurate our
games are when it comes to the portrayal
of the accessories and attachments that
they have to offer
attachments can range from the subtle to
the downright bizarre while many of them
are pretty inconsequential add-ons to a
weapon they're all balanced and
portrayed within the constraints of
their in-game universes rather than
trying to match up to a reality
for example the silencer in call of duty
modern warfare 2 has penalties to things
like range and base damage values
depending on what weapon you fit it to
whereas in reality a modern suppressor
would actually increase the muzzle
velocity of the round now we have done a
whole episode about how games lie to you
about suppressors so you can go and
watch that if you want a full
explanation but this is something many
shooters share where the accessory has
to be balanced within the game and
against other classes attachments or
customization options and due to this
it's often the case that this causes the
in-game betrayal and the real-world
object to diverge quite severely
another strange wrinkle is battlefield's
love for snipers to unlock straight pull
bolts for their bolt action rifles in
reality adding such a system to a bolt
action just wouldn't work but in
battlefield though it's just another
upgrade to chase something for budding
marksmen to add to their weapon to
change up the handling the firearm in
this case allowing shooters to not have
to take their eye from their virtual
scope for follow-up shots it's an
understandable addition as it's no doubt
a challenge for game developers to keep
adding interesting upgrades to their
weaponry but it does create virtual
attachments that are far removed from
their real-world cousins but there's a
great big elephant in the room when it
comes to the realism of these weapon
attachments you see while the virtual
forces and militaries may let you toy
with your issued weapons in the real
world you'll find that this is actually
very rare even your modern warfares your
battlefields that current era so from
2007 onwards where we started getting
modern settings and the ability to
customize firearms in the field as it
were even then your average infantry
soldier has no such ability to configure
their weapon this whole modular
accessorization
phenomenon
comes from the world of special
operations forces and is still quite
limited to that
so you know delta force sas tier one
special force special operations forces
absolutely can set their rifle or
machine gun or whatever up however they
want it before they go on a mission
maybe even partway during a mission in
certain circumstances that's not true of
your average
recruit it complicates logistics it
means that you've got
a mixture of different capabilities in
the same squad when actually you need
them all to have the same capabilities
what we see in games happen in very
narrow circumstances but generally
speaking it's still not common today and
it certainly wasn't common in the mid
20th century and now i'm all for making
custom bits of kit with accessories and
attachments i personally love playing
with all the bells and whistles that
game has to offer even if it isn't in
the game's meta heck my favorite gun in
call of duty modern warfare was
something i simply called long boy
because i wanted to see how massive a
weapon cod would allow me to make
however i am a stickler when it comes to
anachronistic weapon attachments call of
duty world at war dipped its toes into
the trend of reflex sights on mp40s but
it's unfortunately opened the floodgates
for historical settings featuring
misplaced gadgets as time goes on and
tastes in gaming evolve and especially
after the modern warfare era of shooters
where we started to see
current conflicts from places like
afghanistan depicted in video games
unfortunately i'll say unfortunately
it's just my take we see that bleeds
back through into the next generation of
second world war and cold war era kit
because players are now used to the
ability to change
accessories change scopes change grips
change the cosmetics maybe even change
how the weapon functions they're used to
that and they now want to do it or at
least the developers think they want to
do it to stuff that is in a strict
military setting in the past when those
attachments didn't exist and weren't
available and that's where my suspension
of disbelief starts to falter
i think due to the fact that call of
duty did a lot to popularize this game
mechanic that it's become shackled to it
it's now a steadfast staple of the
franchise a staple that's only getting
bigger but perhaps not always for the
best i'm looking at you vanguard m1
garand
and while they're placing historical
titles there's always been a bit of an
eyebrow razor for me when we see games
that are set in the near or far future
using optics and accessories that were
commonplace in the 90s or 2000s it's
also a bit of a head scratcher in one
sense you think
that scope looks awfully like an acog
and it's the year 40 000. but i think
the case is that gamers have now got an
expectation when it comes to add-ons and
developers are playing to that it may be
subconscious but i'm sure there's a case
to be made that the average shooter
player thinks they know what the average
reflex red dot holographic or acog site
should look like so developers try to go
off those aesthetic cues so the gadgets
they put in their games realistic or not
are recognizable and useful at mere
glance cutting down on minor
frustrations and allowing for more time
spent in game and out of menus
and while we can talk about historical
accuracy and realism until the cows come
home those things are always going to be
secondary to things like gameplay
balance player choice and fun
gamers have always been drawn to how
much player choice a game offers and the
amount of options that our favorite
franchises give us you don't have to
look backfire to see marketing campaigns
using lofty numbers advertising how many
millions of types of weapons or
combinations are available at your
disposal more fun things to play with be
they big or small or always going to be
a plus when you're picking up a new
shooter especially with the fact that
for so many of these games you're likely
going to be playing them for a year at
the very least with more of those
options affecting gameplay or weapon
statistics it becomes a bigger challenge
to balance all of those firearm
accoutrements so it's understandable
that devs have to take some liberties
with the whole potential effectiveness
of accessories and add-ons in order to
keep the game balanced as a whole this
whole thing is a bit of a double-edged
sword we talk about realism a lot
what do we mean by realism so on the
level of what's realistic for a soldier
to be using in a given conflict in a
different period games have strayed very
far from that increasingly far with
different wacky accessorizations and
especially the cosmetic options that we
see
and especially in the multiplayer
setting but we do have to consider and i
think give credit that in some ways
these highly customizable weapons are
being very realistic because they are
faithful to the technology that has been
developed in an era appropriate setting
yeah that you know that technology
exists picatinny rails accessories
customization we're usually playing some
sort of special operations forces anyway
it's some fantastical world ending
scenario that's going on i can suspend
disbelief and i can enjoy the
fidelity to the technology if that makes
sense video games are simultaneously
realistic in that they are drawing from
real technology and being replicating it
often very faithfully it's just the
setting that's fantastical and makes it
also unrealistic
that'll do it
good head back
i'm a massive fan of shooters from the
action-packed and arcadey to the slow
paced and tactical and one of the things
that i love most is how that variety can
impact the way that i play i love to see
a weapon list that's not only along with
the number of weapons that i can play
with but also broad with what i can do
with each and every one of them i'm sure
you can guess that i really do love an
essence of realism and authenticity in
my shooters as someone who finds the
subject fascinating and grew up on this
video game genre it has always been
appealing to me i also adore the variety
that our games give us like jonathan
said the more fun i'm having the more my
disbelief is suspended and a greater
level of variety and player choice
serves every player and puts more
options at their fingertips and i think
that's always going to be a good thing
for all the fun tinkering and loadout
building we get to do in our favorite
shooters today i think we can put up
with a few liberties to realism and turn
a blind eye to the odd cursed world war
ii tomigano 2.
thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of loadout in our
upcoming bonus episode we're going to be
having a deeper dive into some specific
attachments so don't miss that but if
you enjoyed this episode please do like
the video and subscribe and make sure
you let your thoughts be known in the
comment section down below or reach out
to me on twitter at irregular dave
if you want more video game weaponry
content you can watch our previous
episode of this show or check out our
weekly series of expert reacts where i
show our friends the royal armory a
selection of video game weapons to break
down until next time i've been your host
dave dewitt thanks again for watching
and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
you